[Musique]
maggie était venu le 7 février dernier
ici au sénat avec son goal son collègue
guillaume lebon nous expliquer cette
réalité sincère franche courageuse
généreuse lucide mais tellement déçue
elle gardait pourtant la foi en sa
mission et un sens du devoir
intact nous l'avions écouter avec
gravité vous ne l'avez pas écoutés mais
vous l'avez fait entendre par l'igpn
pour atteinte à l'image de la police
monsieur le premier ministre
allez vous écoutez comprend des
policiers allez vous entendre à titre
posthume le cri de détresse de maggie je
nous invite à attendre le résultat de
l'enquêté qui a été engagée pour
connaître les raisons de son geste
mais au delà des commentaires qu'il
pourrait y avoir su raisons de son geste
vous m'interrogez sur le mal-être dans
la police ce mal être il est réel et je
ne vous opposerait pas des chiffres
notamment sur les suicides des policiers
qui sont cette année en forte baisse par
rapport à l'année précédente il y a
cette réalité cette réalité de ma lettre
que nous connaissons ce que je sais
monsieur le sénateur c'est qu'il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui de renforcer ses
moyens avec un budget qui augmente de
plus de 1 milliard d'euros en deux ans
avec 300 millions d'euros investis dans
l'immobilier avec un niveau d'équipement
véhicules comme jamais vu mais aussi
monsieur le sénateur avec des
propositions de réforme de la procédure
pénale telle que madame la ministre vous
a présenté la semaine dernière qui
permettent justement d'éviter que les
policiers passent trop de temps dans
cette procédure et soit sur le terrain
parce que c'est leur demande j'ai vu
aussi monsieur le sénateur les choix
politiques qui ont été faits dans cette
assemblée
[Musique]
colbert nous ne pouvons pas taxer les
pauvres puissent qu'ils ne le sont déjà
mazarin les riches non plus il ne
dépenseraient plus mazarin toujours émis
à quantité de gens qui sont entre les
deux ni pauvres ni riches des français
qui travaillent rêvant d'être aux riches
et redoutant des pauvres c'est cela que
nous devons taxer encore plus toujours
plus cela plus tu leur prends plus il
travaille pour compenser c'est un
réservoir inépuisable
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
et bien monsieur le premier ministre
ne pensez vous pas qu aujourd'hui le
réservoir est épuisé nous avons pris des
mesures d'accompagnement parce qu'il
faut accompagner les français dans ce
changement
je pense qu'à l'époque des évidemment de
mazin et de colbert ne se préoccupait
pas beaucoup du dérèglement climatique
et donc nous avons pris des mesures pour
changer de voiture
je ne sais pas monsieur du plomb
monsieur le sénateur du plomb je ne sais
pas si ça vous intéresse mais 250 mille
français ont pu changer de voiture grâce
à une prime à l'achat de 1000 ou 2000
euros moi j'en suis très heureux un
million de français ont pu faire des
travaux d'économie d'énergie cette année
grâce au crédit d'impôt
je pense que c'est une excellente chose
3 millions six cent mille français ont
également bénéficié du chèque énergie et
je crois également que c'est nécessaire
pour passer pour passer ce moment
difficile
n'entendez vous pas le ras-le-bol des
français ils payent plus pour le
carburant plus pour gaz plus pour la cg
alors que dans le même temps votre
gouvernement est incapable de contenir
le déficit public annoncés à près de 100
milliards d'euros en 2019 et de
maîtriser la dette qui sera bientôt à
100% du pib et votre gouvernement d'un
en plus des leçons à tout le monde aux
élus pour leur gestion automobilistes
pour leur conduite à ceux qui fument des
clopes et rouleaux peu au diesel à ceux
qui ne seraient pas assez écologistes
aux progressistes méfiez vous monsieur
le premier ministre
[Musique]